[Musique]
c'est l'un des plus grands requins du
mans c'est aussi l'un des plus méconnus
en 2016 le requin du groenland a connu
son heure de gloire il s'est retrouvé à
la une de la prestigieuse revue science
après que des chercheurs eurent démontré
qu'il pouvait vivre 400 ans
imaginez certains sont nés avant louis
xiv
depuis cette découverte les
scientifiques tentent de comprendre
comment le requin du groenland arrive à
vivre aussi longtemps
pour ce faire une équipe de recherche
internationale est parti en avril
dernier à la rencontre de cet animal
mystérieux qui quittent rarement des
eaux froides et profondes des océans
arctique et de l'atlantique nord
8 physiologiste ont pris la mer au port
de nuuk la capitale du groenland
[Musique]
ils ont navigué vers les fjords au sud
de l'île l'animal se laisse facilement
capturée n'est pas un hasard sur le
surnomme le dormeur du groenland
au cours de l'expédition l'équipe en a
capturé 27 en les appâtant avec de la
chair de fuck
news
des chercheurs mesurent la taille des
animaux puis prélève des échantillons
[Musique]
circle ont été hissés à bord du navire
puis disséquer la fréquence cardiaque de
l'animal est extrêmement basse 12
battements par minute
c'est cinq fois plus lent que le coeur
humain la canadienne enrichi aux
professeurs à l'université de manchester
en angleterre examine un coeur de plus
près à chaque battement
ils pompent un litre de sang
[Musique]
contrairement aux humains chez qui le
coeur se durcit avec l'âge les requin du
groenland même plusieurs fois
centenaires semble conserver hackers
souple ce qui facilite les contractions
[Musique]
les scientifiques espèrent identifier la
clé de leur longévité est peut-être en
faire profiter le coeur humain
les chercheurs ont aussi étudié comment
l'animal réussi à capturer ses proies à
cause de son allure nonchalante
on a longtemps cru que le requin du
groenland était un charognard qui se
contentent des carcasses d'animaux morts
pour se nourrir or des scientifiques ont
trouvé des morceaux de phoques frais
dans son estomac ce qui laisse croire
qu'il serait aussi un chasseur
pourtant les analyses faites sur la
queue de l'animal ont montré que si
muscles ne sont pas assez puissants pour
lui permettre d'accélérer au delà de
deux kilomètres à l'heure peut-être ça
tactile aux phoques
pendant qu'ils dorment dans l'eau c'est
un mystère
[Musique]
les vingt-sept requins capturés 21 ont
été relâchés en mer certains ont été
munies de balises satellites pour suivre
leurs déplacements
l'analyse des données se poursuivra au
cours des prochains mois
qui sait les requins du groenland nous
montreront peut-être un jour le chemin
vers la fontaine de jouvence